do you think about social media its its
quote free right but what do we what are
we actually paying with we're paying
with our time we're paying with our
attention and I think it's increasingly
obvious that we're paying with our
mental health a lot of this is tied up
with our obsession with work as like our
only way of expressing value the
clearest thing is that we somehow are
one of literally two countries in the
world that don't have paid family leave
for new moms you know because that
somehow would be like bad for business
I think acknowledging human
vulnerability and struggles is also bad
for business like you're depressed you
know keep it to yourself
[Music]
before this pandemic we already had
record highs in terms of our stress
levels anxiety depression prescription
drug use and even suicides and drug
overdoses it had gotten so bad that our
life expectancy declined for three years
in a row which was unheard of
essentially in a developed country and
so that's pre crisis and the worst part
is obviously this crisis has doubled or
tripled the incidence of depression
anxiety mental health issues around the
country people with kids of which I am
one who report having severe distress
went up from three percent to thirty
seven percent and I understand why
I mean I'm trapped with a four year old
a seven year old one of whom is on the
autism spectrum and one or the other of
them is having some kind of meltdown
several times a day and so you know
you're you just around like a screaming
child a lot which elevates your stress
level and if you look at the crisis text
line which is a line that you contact if
you are considering hurting yourself
there traffic has gone up a hundred
percent so you're looking at two to
three times or worse in terms of
exacerbating a pre-existing mental
health crisis in this country I'm really
passionate about this on a personal
level my brother is a psychology
professor and there's so much more that
we must do now more than ever one of the
things that stood out to me in your book
before I joined your campaign was
talking about and I you probably
remember this but on how specific you
remembered talking about how people
inside like at the top of the food chain
like people at like in the 1% are
actually miserable as well as the people
at the in the bottom part of that
country remember writing about that yeah
I remember looking at the numbers
because I'm a numbers guy about studies
of how kids were doing on college
campuses and all the way up to
the most selective schools kids were
reporting again record high levels of
anxiety and depression and existential
stress and worse and you had queues out
the door for counseling and mental
health resources at these schools to the
point where the schools were doubling
tripling like the number of counselors
and psychologists and associate deans
that they had on staff to see all the
kids and they still weren't able to
actually meet with them where you had
like multi month waiting lists at these
schools and these are the kids who had
quote-unquote done it you know they'd
like graduated from high school at the
top of their class they got into that
school that everyone wanted to get into
and then they're freakin miserable when
they get there and then it's not like oh
but after they get out of college it'll
like you know it'll become sunshine and
roses
yes post-collegiate landscape is
changing too
and many many people have life changing
levels of debt which is a stressor I
know that too because I had school loans
of over a hundred thousand dollars in my
20s so these are the people that had had
supposedly one in our meritocratic rat
race and they also were depressed as
heck and you worked on Wall Street and
it's not like people there were happy
right well you get these kids that go to
elite school what they do well in high
school they gonna leap college and
university and then they get an elite
job so they're going to Harvard then
they go to McKinsey and then that
environment they go into is cutthroat
and intense and stress inducing just the
work itself let alone the people so I
think most of shocking means like okay
here's the winners they're miserable and
then you know people who are financially
struggling that causes its own level of
misery plus some of the jobs are harder
they're physically harder and more
taxing you've talked a lot about truck
drivers and what that does is someone's
body so if the the winners are miserable
and
losers are miserable what are we doing
what are we doing and a lot of this is
tied up with our obsession with work as
like our only way of expressing value or
our only way of measuring ourselves or
other people when I talk to a Barack
Obama about a number of things like a
few weeks ago and one thing he said that
we should look at which I agree with
wholeheartedly which is related to
mental health he's having shorter work
weeks right now our work weeks just get
keep on creeping longer and longer and
if you were to shorten them you would
create some jobs in the margins because
you might have to hire some extra people
and in certain roles and organizations
and functions but you'd also give people
a chance to breathe have their head up
think about the things that are
important to them that are not work work
work Derek Thompson journalist the
Atlantic calls it work ISM it's like the
religion of America and it's one reason
why we're so stressed out anxious but
it's also one reason why we're having
trouble humanizing the economy and
having measures like universal basic
income because people are so obsessed
with the facts I go but then you might
not work to find you know it ignores all
these forms of work that people actually
want to do which might make us less sad
anxious and depressed particularly now
you know that mean the numbers are
staggering around the magnitude of the
mental health crisis during this
pandemic and we have to have massive
investments to try and improve the
situation because this is a crisis on
top of a pre-existing crisis there's one
of the things I've kind of taken away
and working from home a lot is that I
probably don't do five fold days of work
right like my work comes in fits and
starts like I'm just it's like it's like
like I'll work like 15 hours straight
and then you know I get it less done the
next day or
it right like I do think if you actually
budget your time in this environment you
would probably find you could get more
done on a four hour workweek or sorry a
four-day workweek four hour work weeks
different book o studies have shown in
terms of time use that four-day Work
Week is just about as productive as a
five-day workweek and that extra day and
we kind of know how we we organize our
own time it's like somehow the time you
allocate shrinks or expands to fit the
schedule it's like could I get this
thing done in three days sure you give
me five days I'll do it then you do it
four days like pretty much whatever type
rave you give me I'll get it done
there's days on that where you give a
human being the same number of tasks in
more time or less time and they'll still
do it they'll do it in less time most of
the time I want to go on the record and
say to that in my 20s I tried to start a
business we didn't have any money so we
were like work from home and I sucked at
it and it was miserable and I said to
myself like I'm going to try to not do
this again that so for people who think
working from home is awful because of
like a lack of division or separation
between work and the rest of your life
and like schedule creep and the rest of
it like I feel your pain because yeah I
hated it in my 20s and yeah like you
know obviously not now it's like it's a
slightly different situation but I I'm
not sure whether working from home is
good or bad for your mental health
because I think it could cut both ways
what I'm finding is challenging is that
I used to have like my computer time
where I do my work and then I have
meetings or interactions or go get a cup
of coffee or go get lunch with somebody
and that's non screen time and now with
zoom and these zoom calls video calls
like my people interaction time is
screen time and then my work times also
screen time and then it just blends
together your brain kind of mushes and
that's probably you do too like you're
doing all these like video conference
press hits and that's got to be
infuriating in some ways
yeah it's uh it's not great for your
mental health it's one reason why I do
try and get outside and get some fresh
air every day and so some of the things
that I've been doing immediately just to
keep my head on straight and this is a
time for self-care if you're listening
to this just know like you have to try
and look out for yourself because if you
don't look out for yourself
you'll probably be depressed and right
now if you are depressed you're
perfectly normal and if you're not
depressed you're probably a little weird
because most people so some of the
things I do that have helped me exercise
get some outdoor time every day reach
out to someone for something
non-work-related randomly every day try
and read something like I think I am a
fan of just analog like hardcover
softcover books right and reading a book
has been tied to positive mental states
and mental health it's relaxing what are
you reading right now I'm reading books
from people that are gonna be on the
podcast so right now I'm reading
humankind by Rutger Bregman so if you're
a Rutger Bergman Fanny it's gonna be on
the pocket and I read an earlier version
before because I gave a blurb for the
book but it's changed a little bit and I
wanted to read it again there are very
very big structural changes we should be
making in terms of our approach to
mental health it would start with D
stigmatizing it so one thing I said that
people always got a laugh out of was to
say we should have a psychologist in the
White House and people thought that was
just like me knocking Trump but it's
just good practice I mean you have
people in a very stressful environment
and it would be stigmatize mental health
issues because it's like oh if folks in
the at the in the White House say like
there's a psychologist on staff and they
they see the person that's something
maybe we should all be doing I think the
stigma around injured to me bothers me
so much mainly because I'm not sure
where it's coming from because this kind
of thing is actually I mean what's the
phrase in the Bible is like one man
iron sharpens iron one man sharpens
another like this is actually something
that if you're like that far away is
gonna stigmatize it whoever it is like
that's something that talking each other
it's kind of in par for the course as
human beings for a while I don't know
where the stigma came from Andrew we
just somehow got afraid of this I think
the sting was associated with a lot of
things Zach it's like there's like this
pathological competitiveness efficiency
mentality the worship of work I mean
that the clearest thing is that we
somehow are one of literally two
countries in the world that don't have
paid family leave for new moms right you
know because that somehow would be like
bad for business
I think acknowledging human
vulnerability and struggles is also bad
for business like you're depressed you
know keep it to yourself you know that
is such like a worship of toughing it
out or Manning up you know in every
aspect of American culture really so I
think the sting was actually associated
with our hyper capitalist interested
institutions to him like that there it's
really pervasive there's probably short
term and long term solutions we can do
from a policy standpoint you have a
bunch of ideas where would you start
there are so many things that we can do
to invest in our mental health I mean we
have to make sure that our existing
resources stay open number one we have
to fund things like the crisis text line
that right now are dependent upon
philanthropy and volunteers just have to
make sure that the resources that exist
have what they need to to meet the needs
we have many mental health centers that
are getting defunded right now and are
closing so we need to fund them properly
we should be loosening any restrictions
on psychologists or counselors or
therapists or psychiatrists seeing
people over the internet where right now
there are actually state by state
licensing requirements which really
don't make a whole lot of sense because
like does a human mind change but
Queen Connecticut and oh I can't see a
Vermonters brain totally differently so
we have to try and enable telepsychiatry
to a higher degree we should be
loosening up the restrictions for
paraprofessionals who might be able to
help in a crisis who might not have had
like you know the particular testing or
credentialing or training but if you
have someone who's being trained who can
then consult with someone who has years
of experience that can help build
capacity we should make measuring our
mental health one of like the key things
we use to see how we're doing where
instead of paying attention to the stock
market and GDP numbers which are
increasingly valueless we should just
see how our mental health is and then we
would know what is going on in our
communities which again is like a crisis
that is deepening we should be training
more and more therapists and counselors
and psychologists and make it easier and
cheaper we should be hiring many of
those people through the public because
we need to create millions of jobs right
now in this society
we've lost thirty eight and a half
million jobs officially unofficially the
damage is worse the permanent job loss
is estimated to be 42 percent of the
total so 42 percent of 38 million is 15
to 16 million of permanent jobs lost and
for reference the Great Recession cost
us eight point eight million jobs so
you're looking at something that's
almost two times the Great Recession
permanently and then another let's call
it twenty million jobs that may or may
not come back we hope they will and so
you need to be trying to find employment
opportunities for millions of American
enemy hiring social workers counselors
therapists training psychologists like
that this can be a nation scale
initiative we should be connecting
mental health to physical health and say
look they're the same freakin thing if
you see a doctor there should just be a
therapist down the hall it would be like
hey you want to see me too
they did this in Alaska and it had
massive impact where it turns out
physical health problems are tied to
mental health problems a lot of the time
right you talk about getting mental
health resources to cops - or law
enforcement officials talk about a
stressful job you know like there were
studies about how like many many police
officers are struggling with
post-traumatic stress disorder because
of some experience they had in the field
so that that's a an area of investment
that I feel like everyone to get behind
because you're a cop you'd be like sure
like you know like that'd be great and
if you're a member of the public you'd
be like great like you know happier
healthier cops so there are a lot of
things that we should be doing bigger
and better when it comes to mental
health but number one is recognizing
that it's universal we all struggle and
that we have a crisis that has been made
much much worse by this pandemic this
podcast is sponsored by outturn own and
I have to say after outturn own sent me
some clothes I then went back to their
website and bought some more because
Evelyn liked it I liked it it's super
comfortable you know that it was not
made by like you know little kids who
are having their knuckles broken or
anything like it's like being produced
in the right way it's sustainable it's
comfortable and so I did exactly what
they're saying you can do which is I
went to a door known calm I ordered
clothes and I entered the code yang and
I got 25% off my in my order so I know
it works because I did it I cannot tell
you how fantastic and rare this is right
now you've gotten
yang passionately and proactively
talking about clothes this was the pain
point me on a campaign you never cared
about how he dressed never care how I
look
you didn't care the brand nothing and
right now he just said to me I want to
rerecord the outter known ad because I
love it and I went out and went back and
bought more so this clothing brand has
gotten Andrew yang to care about
clothing it's that good and I'm wearing
mine right now to also love it so I
don't know calm use the yang code
because yang loves it and you get 25%
off but yeah these guys got yang to care
about clothing and that is a feat you
got a whole book on job losses basically
causing more mental health issues and
creating a sense of crisis right so you
have this vicious cycle right now we're
losing more jobs its deteriorate to
health and then because of that we're
investing we're able to best lesson
until health resource and people getting
worse what what are the social
consequences that start happening if we
as a country and we as families start
deteriorating mentally and if you lack
of a better term there if we don't get
this right what does the future look
like well to me the unit of an economy
or society is each person and so if you
look around and say are we setting our
kids up for success like are we going to
give rise to strong healthy adults who
then start families themselves and can
lead healthy fulfilling lives for
decades to come
and so if you have a mental health
crisis and an economic crisis and a
public health crisis like all stacked on
top of each other
you're not giving individuals a chance
to prosper and succeed and then that
degrades your educational outcomes like
your ability to create jobs or perform
at all economically to have a
functioning democracy over time to me
the stuffs not marginal it's like oh
that's nice yeah like some it's a
therapy be great like it like
is fundamental where we have to make
ourselves stronger as individuals to
have a strong society so that's not a
bad segue Andrew into something we're
trying now which is asking speaks so if
you use the hashtag asking speaks will
pull your questions and will try to use
them weekly tied to the topic we're
discussing or highlighting on the show
so this is Mental Health Awareness Week
and this questions from Izzy Bolden on
Twitter is he asked can you go into
detail as to why we have major stigmas
for people with mental illnesses which
kneeing we kind of talked about but is
he a specifically on learning and kind
of individual invisible disabilities so
why do people in the society treat
people with disabilities or things they
don't understand in humanely well is he
I wish that we didn't stigmatize these
issues and one of the things I say as a
parent of an autistic child is that
being neurologically different is the
new normal and I do genuinely think it's
tied to the fact that we see everyone as
like an economic actor input and then
it's like well if you're not producing
value in a particular way that we can
all understand in the market place then
you're worthless
and it's all tied together like it's one
reason why I'm so passionate about
universal basic income is I think that
making the statement that everyone is
worth something intrinsically actually
ends up combating these sorts of stigmas
and make it seem like well it turns out
the market does not tell us how much
we're worth I think that's one reason
why people who are neurologically
different or have different issues and
disabilities get marginalized the way
they do here in the United States hi I
will say this and this is probably more
touchy-feely than Andrew ever gets but
I'll say this like look for you there's
tens of thousands of seen these
listening this episode every time
whatever you're going through whatever
you're thinking whatever anxiety - like
negative thoughts you're having because
of the Panda
you're not alone you we're all feeling
it too so I want you guys to know you're
loved and it's gonna get better
and we're fighting for you and hopefully
this podcast is a way for you to feel
that you're heard and that other people
are having these conversations too and
we hope we hope this is a beacon for you
in some way one person who's focused on
the health of our kids is my guest or
our guest this week dr. Jean Twenge who
is so thoughtful and profound in trying
to figure out how we're going to make
our kids stronger if your family's
anything like mine and you have kids
right now screen time has gone from
something that you were like oh can't
have too much to like here it is this is
your day so I am so pumped to talk to
Jean Twenge
one of the foremost world leaders in
studying what the heck happens to our
kids we get too much screen time so if
you're a parent this thing is for you
and if you're not a parent and you're
young and you're also on the screens all
the freaking time because we're all
stuck indoors you should tune into just
to see what the heck is happening to
your brain doctor twing you wrote this
book called ijen and you Andrew when I
first started you gave me a couple books
to read and this was one you were very
passionate writing you have to read this
yeah Jean jeans tremendous I am so
excited that she came on to share some
of her learnings with us I learned a ton
from her and I hope everyone does
[Music]
now one of the things that I ran on was
the fact that we have a mental health
crisis in this country that there are
record levels of depression anxiety even
suicide and self-harm and one of the
huge learnings from your book was that
there was a surge in depression and
anxiety among young people that
hand-in-hand with widespread smartphone
adoption and the use of social media
there really is a mental health crisis
and I don't think that's an
overstatement at all
for adolescents for young adults we see
these really striking increases in
depression in anxiety in unhappiness
loneliness and those have been either
unchanged or actually improving for a
while then about 2011 or 2012 they start
to rise in these very very steep
patterns and it's not just Survey data
it's not just people saying you know I
you know I'm not happy you know I feel
useless or or like I don't enjoy life
they're saying that it also shows up in
behavior so it's not just about self
reports emergency room admissions for
self-harm behaviors have skyrocketed
same thing your visits for thinking
about suicide or attempting suicide for
teenagers have gone way up and most
tragic of all the actual suicide rate
has doubled or even tripled for young
people since 2010 so you look at all of
that data it's so consistent the the
changes are so large the next question
you have to try to answer is why what
happened
that might explain you know why this is
going on and when I first started to see
these trends I had absolutely no idea
what the cause could be it was a real
mystery it was actually misaligned with
economic trends because
that period from 2011 to the latest data
we have is 2018 that was a period of
economic expansion thinks we're doing
things were going fairly well in in the
economy at least in terms of
unemployment and so on so it actually
was misaligned with that and it was hard
to think of any other event that
happened around that time it kept going
in the same direction especially
something that had a big effect on
people's lives but then one day I
stumbled across a poll from the Pew
Center for Research that showed the end
of 2012 was the first time that the
majority of Americans own smartphones
and that's when I started to realize
maybe that might have something to do
with it
that as everyone adopted smartphones as
social media use among teens moved from
optional to mandatory that was happening
at the same time it was just it was
happening at the same time it was that
that had a really big effect on teens
day to day lives
it wasn't something happened their
parents what did he write about in the
news that shift in how they use their
time outside of school is something that
was happening happening to them every
single day for hours at a time they were
spending a lot more time on their phones
and social media and online and a lot
less time with their friends face to
face and that's just not a good formula
for mental health we need that in-person
social interaction to be healthy can you
dig into why you became convinced that
smartphones and social media adoption
was the strongest explanation yeah you
know it really was a process of thinking
about what changed in the culture that
had the biggest effect on people because
if you think about big events sometimes
events are things that affect a small
number of people it's quite a bit but
then for everyone else it's something
that they hear about or read about
there's other events like the corona
virus outbreak for exam
it's not just one localized event or
something that is having an effect on a
few people it's something that is having
an effect on almost everyone for weeks
and months at a time so it's like a big
natural experiment and the adoption of
smartphones was also a big natural
experiment of a totally different type
but it's something that had an effect in
people's day-to-day lives generally
those are the things that are gonna have
the most impact on personal mental
health and happiness and the impact of
smartphones was pretty striking that if
you look at teens and see you know how
just how they're spending their time
outside of school it used to be that
they would spend lots of time with their
friends face-to-face and now they spent
a lot less time with their friends
face-to-face and a lot more time
communicating electronically the other
shift is that between 2012 2018 teens
were sleeping less possibly because they
were staying up late and their devices
and that was interfering with sleep so
you put those things together of
spending less time with friends in
person getting less sleep that is gonna
have an impact on mental health even if
we say you know screens aren't that bad
whatever that displacement of things
that are better for mental health might
alone account for the mental health
issues I don't think they do I think
there's other things going on there in
terms of what is going on online and
some of the harmful information that
some kids are getting online but that's
a big part of it not screens themselves
but what they were placed on the other
end the technology companies I'd like to
quote my friend Tristan Harris who has
said we have some of the smartest
engineers in our country turning
supercomputers into dopamine delivery
devices and slot machines for teenagers
and all
their economic incentives are around
maximizing engagement for advertising
revenue and so where is the mental
health consideration in the design of
these apps or technologies completely
absent like if your Facebook you know
you just start trying to gin up ad
revenue in any way you can and anything
you do that's going to end up maximizing
engagement you're going to gravitate
towards and so like you said this is a
giant natural experiment if you think
about what would be the counterweight
for the designers and the investment on
the technology side it would
theoretically be someone in the room
being like hey maybe you should dial
that back a notch or maybe like after
someone's been using the app or the
phone for more than 20 hours that week
like you might wanna like have some kind
of notification or something along those
lines like this that that is not
happening
in large part because our government is
decades behind the curve when it comes
to any of these issues that we got rid
of the office of Technology Assessment
literally over 20 years ago and so there
is no one even advising Congress on
technology related issues aside from the
technology companies themselves and that
that's the problem I mean it's it's
really you know on unregulated and I
mean in the good news is say you know if
you're making smart phones say Apple for
example they've introduced this program
called screen time that actually will
give you a little bit of a heads-up of
hey here's what happened you know on
Sunday essentially this notification of
your screen time was up your screen
times down and here much here's how much
it was but that makes sense their
business model is gonna be you buy the
phone you're good social media companies
for example you're exactly right
they make more money the more time
people spend on this so if there's a 13
year old who's spending 10 hours a day
on Instagram that's one of their best
customers says what they want that's how
you make the most money
and I love Tristan Harris's work he his
philosophy these are just a wonderful
way to sum it up is time well spent and
that's what we have to do not give up
technology technology's great
it's just that we shouldn't be spending
all of our waking hours on it that there
has to be some limit we have to think
more mindfully about how we're spending
our time and that's the key because you
think about social media and it's it's
quote free right but what do we what are
we actually paying with we're paying
with our time we're paying with our
attention and I think it's increasingly
obvious that we're paying with our
mental health and the mental health of
our children so you know these these are
not small issues these this is it this
is a big deal all right if you're
listening to this you are obviously a
fan of podcasts and one of the best
podcasts out there is the Jordan
Harbinger show it's an apple top 50
podcasts it's one of Apple's best 2018
podcasts and well and we love it it's
got a frankly a range of topics ranging
from talking to FBI negotiators about
how to deal with hostage situations
you've got mental health situations
you've got Tony Hawk on there you've got
such a wide range of topics and Jordans
such a fascinating guy so it's not pop
psychology your superficial advice or BS
inspirational nonsense it's a show that
offers meaningful fun life-changing
insights with a practical edge and I
love the worksheets because I come away
with like what I'm supposed to do from
an episode like this and there's no BS
it's very straightforward and simple for
someone like me yeah yeah it's really
good listening good learning good
information from experts that you kind
of wish you had access to and now
Jordan's done it for you check out the
Jordan Harbinger show Jordan Harbinger
calm sigh subscribe
Apple Spotify wherever you get your
podcasts let's imagine gene for a moment
I'm the president United States and I'm
just gonna do whatever you tell me is
the right thing to do so what would you
tell us to do so there's a couple things
one is now I'm not I'm not a lawyer
however my understanding of the 98 law
is that
people under the age of 13 are not
allowed to have a social media account
in their own name yet it's never
enforced and there are lots of 12 11 10
even 9 7 8 year old kids who have social
media accounts and they just they just
put a different birthday in and they're
good and then they have a social media
account sometimes their parents don't
even know about it because the average
age to get your first smartphone is now
10 so they have their own device if that
device hasn't been you know set up with
parental controls by their parents which
usually they're not then they go and get
a social media account and they're good
so start buying enforcing existing law
on that number two would be to consider
doing what France is done and saying no
smartphones during the school day at
school
so when kids are at school then that
phone is put in a locker or someplace
safe and they get it back at the end of
the day so Bell de Bell no phones and
that accomplishes two things first
there's not as many distractions in the
classroom you talk to any high school
teacher they'll tell you it's like a
constant battle trying to get kids to
put those phones away and then second
then they'll actually talk to each other
at lunch because you know what middle in
high schools are like now and you go
into the lunchroom they're shockingly
quiet because the kids are all on their
phones they're not talking to each other
that is very depressing and I'm sure
accurate and quite dystopian it is and I
mean that that's the other thing that a
lot of people are concerned about is
that we're kids going to get developed
social skills and that's what they
really need so yeah come on they'll be
on snapchat though you know like they'll
learn very many important social lessons
via tick-tock right you know
maybe they will but I I was joking on
the trails like tick-tock
when Instagram is too intellectual like
exactly I want to return to these policy
recommendations because both of them are
a slam dunk some
obviously if you have a law in the books
you should have some kind of real and I
won't say enforcement but like
accountability and bail de belles no
smartphone just seems common sense to me
I was a very shy nerdy introverted kid
but when I was 12 years old and I went
home and I shut the door I was alone
today that 12 year old kid shuts the
door and then everyone in their schools
in the room with them because they he
does turn on their phone and just see
what everyone's up to see what
everyone's saying and thinking and
presenting and I cannot imagine what
that would be like because for me like
if I had a tough day at school and a lot
of them were tough days and I closed my
door then now was it like no-one's like
following me home you know what I mean
well like those kids getting followed
home that to me seems very very
difficult like it would fundamentally
change your sense of privacy solitude
you know it's especially when you're
young because we all remember when
you're kids like what other kids are
saying and thinking about you seems like
the entire world absolutely and you know
when you're teenager that that is kind
of the time when people develop social
skills and relationship skills and
friendships and communication skills and
all those things are really really
coming together at that time and the
norm is just completely shifted I mean
there's just an enormous drop in kids
just hanging out with each other so
there's one of these big surveys that I
analyze says this question you know how
often do you get together with your
friends informally so just you know
that's that's a great question it's very
broad it's something that you know most
parents would approve of it's not
something illicit you know how could you
do that and back in the 80s when I was
Gen Xers you were doing about 50 percent
of teens said yeah I do that every day
and now it's about 25 so it's been cut
in half and across the board whether
it's you know going to out to movies to
parties walking around the mall all
those things that used to be
the daily life of teens ijen teens just
don't do them as much no every once in a
while but it's much more rare so that
interaction and communication has moved
online and you know sometimes people ask
me well don't you think in the future
you know all the communications gonna be
completely online anyway well maybe
maybe some of it but especially once out
of our houses social skills never gonna
go away that true human connection that
is something that can't be automated
it's something that's always going to be
important and it's something a lot of
kids are missing out on and they were
missing out on and even before the
corona virus outbreak so you are on your
second recommendation which was no cell
phones and no smart phones in schools
which makes perfect sense to me are
there more things you'd like to tell our
hypothetical president you could explore
instead of it being 13 to have a social
media account maybe it should be 60 so
that would be another thing to consider
for kids to just be a little bit more
mature beyond that it's gonna be more a
matter of how can we educate both kids
and their parents about basically do you
know digital hygiene there's all talk in
schools about digital citizenship which
I get but I think it ignores some of the
basics around well there's a time to be
on technology and then there are times
we should not be on technology so we
were talking about sleep earlier that
has to be number one when I when I give
talks to you high school parents and
high school and middle school students
themselves I always tell them if you
want to just take one thing away from
this talk it should be this
we shouldn't have our phones or tablets
in our bedrooms overnight and if you
want to regulate that as a parent go
into the parental controls and have that
phone or
goblet or laptop become a brick at
bedtime just have it it doesn't work
anymore so that's what we do in in in
our house with my 13 year old she
doesn't have a phone but she has a
laptop and it just doesn't work it
doesn't work after nine o'clock and and
then you know if you're not tech savvy
and you don't want to go in and mess
with that I get it
then you just physically take it put it
on a charger downstairs or away from the
bedrooms or you know if that even that
doesn't work by a lockbox put it in
there lock it up at night just we
shouldn't be having these in our phone
in in the bedroom overnight and that
goes for adults too by the way we really
need to have our sleep preserve our
sleep and then if you're wondering this
is the question I usually get at this
point well wait I have to have my phone
in my bedroom overnight because it's my
alarm clock I have some advice for you
buy an alarm clock you can buy it on
Amazon on your phone and then put your
phone away and get a good night's sleep
completely agree by the way like that of
trying to get your smart phones and
devices out of your room
Arianna my friend Arianna Huffington
recommended that a little while ago and
I was like ooh that's a good idea
so yeah more it more concrete lessons
for parents like me do you do anything
else with your three girls yeah so the
other thing is you don't want to be on
an electronic device right before
bedtime
so there's this enormous body of
research on this from sleep researchers
that and they do this in sleep labs as
well as at people's homes so there's you
know all kinds of different methods and
all converges on this that you shouldn't
be on a device within about an hour of
bed time if at all possible it's for two
really big reasons first pretty much
everything we do on phones and tablets
is psychologically stimulating you know
social media texting shopping whatever
it is it gets our brains going at a time
when we need to be relaxing before bed
there's a physiological element to it as
well that the blue light from these
devices shines into our eyes tricks our
brains and I think it's still daytime
and
then we don't produce the melatonin and
the sleep hormone that we need to have
to fall asleep quickly and get a good
night's sleep so then the question
people has have is well then what do I
do
before I go to bed well you know people
have going been going to sleep for
centuries without scrolling through
Instagram so it is possible and you
think about what to replace it with so
reading you can read a book or recommend
by Jean Twenge well thank you but you
can you can read anything you like and
if and if you use a Kindle that's fine
because it can say a kindle paperweight
you just turn the light all the way off
you read an iPad or if you watch TV
those have blue light they don't the
psychological stimulation so you're good
more or less good there but you can wear
orange safety glasses to filter out the
blue light so that's actually what what
we do in our house our rule is you
either read or watch TV before you go to
bed so no other devices but if you're
gonna watch TV before you go to bed then
you wear these $10 orange safety glasses
to filter out the blue light
[Applause]
are you in quarantine and eating like
[ __ ] are you tired of making easy mac
and cheese or chicken parmesan TV dinner
that's not good for you
freshly delivers food to your door and
it's actually healthy I'm a huge fan so
this is not the situation where they
send you ingredients and you do work
this is no work yeah which is my style
like you get that dinner and you just
eat it up in its delicious immediately
like heap for three minutes these are
like guy proof instructions you know
it's like you just can't screw it up
instead of freshly they should call it
can't screw it up Lee jawed our producer
has been using it and he swears by it
says it's delicious and makes it feel
good about himself and it's actually
helping him reach his health and fitness
goals while stuck at home so that's a
very very high bar so can't screw it up
Lee is offering our listeners $40
freshly is offering our listeners $40
off their first two orders at freshly
dot-com slash yang that's freshly
dot-com slash yang I tried to make fish
last night and it was an epic disaster
burnt disgusting it tasted like fish and
yet I mean that in a bad way
you know so don't do it I did in order
of freshly freshly com /y ang yet $40
off your first two orders fresh c-calm
slashing
[Music]
[Applause]
you are you know like PhD a professor
one of like the foremost authorities on
this and like the fact that you're
taking countermeasures with your girls
is tremendous but most Americans are in
a position where they're just you know
just trying to get through a day they
might be working two jobs like their
kids are left on their own for like you
know most of the time in our current era
of pervasive financial insecurity where
if you're a parent like you're just
trying to like you know keep a roof over
the head and then what the kids are
doing it's it's pretty much like a
free-for-all you know like imagining
that we're gonna be able to figure out
everything our kids are doing at any
moment in time strikes me as frankly
ridiculous and so then you go back to
the source of it and you have these tech
companies again in some cases trillion
dollar companies minting like billions
of dollars and so that's one end of the
equation and then the other end is that
13-year old girl in Albuquerque New
Mexico
like getting depressed and so instead of
saying like hey that girl's parent
should really get in there and figure
out what the heck the daughter is doing
or like lying about her age or whatever
it happens to be like I think that's
stupid I think we should go straight to
the tech companies and say hey guys
check it out like your interest is
making lots of money our interest is not
screwing up our kids wholesale and like
wrecking generations and making it so
that like our kids are you know heading
to emergency rooms and like our anxious
and depressed even if they're fortunate
enough to be at the upper end of the
educational spectrum they show up to
college they're super depressed so
you're gonna have to dial it back you
know it's like you you should not just
have a higher age for social media
accounts but maybe there should be like
sort of like a hygiene limit on how much
they can like snap every day it's like
and you can set the limit at something
like reasonably high but not 10 hours a
day high like and I would put our friend
Tristan Harris in charge of it
incidentally I think his name is
pronounced Tristan even though it's
spell Dristan so what I mean obviously
I'm sure he gets that all the time but
so I'd put our friend Tristan in charge
of it and say hey time well-spent like
that is actually what should be
happening in our society and I believe
that some of the tech companies are
increasingly open to this because a lot
of them have kids now like the founders
have kids and one of the things I said
when I was on the campaign trail is that
if you want to go to a place where they
police screen time very very rigorously
go to Silicon Valley because those
parents know what is going on in these
apps and technologies and they don't let
their kids use it like so think about
what that says so I just want to say
like your wish list is a hundred percent
correct but we're gonna have to go much
much bigger if we're actually going to
get into the root of this problem
because government right now is decades
behind the curve parents are outgunned
this is a role for us to actually try
and say look like we have to make real
decisions as to what is best for our
kids and I'm very very sure that what's
best for our kids is not let the tech
companies just figure it out on their
own I mean there has to be something
where at least for minors so so you know
ages 17 and under that there can be more
regulation of this just like people were
eventually successful in getting more
regulation around children's television
that we could have more regulation you
know around social media and you know we
have to be thoughtful about it because
you know there's 15 year-olds out there
who are just starting their own business
and maybe they need to be on Instagram
for that so we have to you know kind of
recognize that but there's there are
reasonable limits and we can think about
certain platforms they you know
snapchats a great example it is arguably
you know not as bad as say Instagram
because you know on Instagram there's
too many teenage girls who are taking a
200
these selfies to get the right wine and
there's so much body image emphasis and
so on it you know might be part of the
reason why we have so much depression
and those trends are stronger among
girls but then we get snapchat where
nobody's using that for work who are we
kidding and there are kids who are yeah
on it 810 hours a day so we have to
think about like reasonable limits
there's lots of things you can do with
technology and lots of things you can do
online that are very productive that are
very positive and there's things that
aren't and that's what makes it so hard
I think to regulate it is I mean let's
take you know to take two people who
both you look at their their screen time
report on their smartphone says they
spend eight hours a day online well one
of them is a pizza delivery person and
seven hours of that is on the maps
function well they're probably fine but
then you know the other is a
twelve-year-old girl who you know lied
about her birthday and has spent seven
out of those eight hours on Instagram
that's a different situation so that's
gonna be I think the the huge challenge
and trying to regulate stuff is it has
to be more specific and you know parents
can do that now but you're right it
shouldn't just be on parents that really
is the big why of like Oh parents can do
can do everything well we're stretched
thin and there's only so much that we
can do so you're right we need help and
I think what seems you have all this
stuff that all this passing data on kids
and now we're in quarantine so that's
it's hitting the kids probably double
but it's also in the adults too because
we're all on our screens all day long -
what'd I miss - start that thoughts on
coronavirus and quarantine right now and
how your research is applying to the
crisis written today so it's not all bad
you know we're getting probably more you
know face to face time with her with our
families and so for younger kids they
miss their friends but they're getting
bike so like hey mom and dad are around
more but with teens that's where it
becomes really really hard because just
as we were talking about how much you
know college was
let's get out of here that starts in 12
or 13 when they want to have their own
lives and their own social life with
their friends and that's gone I mean in
terms of in person
that is gone right now it is not
happening so they rely on electronic
communication and you know I suppose you
can see that as an up side band they
know how to do that but the fundamental
psychology of humans has not changed it
is not the same to communicate with your
friends on Instagram as it is to be with
them in person and if you look at the
trends that cause the mental health
crisis that we were in even before this
started they were less face-to-face
interaction more electronic
communication now we're at a next level
for that so that's what has me really
concerned is that for everybody we are
not spending as much time with people
face-to-face or in person so we have to
think about in this situation what can
we do to try to replace that and I think
the answer most of the time is gonna be
video chat so Skype or FaceTime or zoom
where you are interacting in real time
you can see the other person's face and
it's still not the same as being able to
be in the same room with someone but
it's the closest we can get and so with
our kids we can encourage them in that
direction instead of you know spending
even more time on Instagram or snapchat
or tik-tok that lets communicate with
our friends by doing a video call and I
Jen's low allergic to that the idea of
like calling somebody is kind of foreign
to them even when it comes to video chat
and video calls whether it's teens or
adults you know you can you can send
that text and say hey you know sometime
this evening let's let's do FaceTime um
and it's it's
it's a best substitute right now I've
got two young boys seven and four one of
them is autistic and one of the things
that gave me joy was dropping off both
of them to school because both of them
struggle with social skills and so just
what it took for them to traffic getting
through a school day with you know like
25 other 7 year olds or 4 year olds like
I knew that was really exactly what they
needed and they're not getting that now
you know it's like that they have some
online sessions that are better than
nothing but are certainly not the same
we have to try to find the positive in
this situation and potentially you
especially for kids so maybe a little
bit older than than yours but you know
my kids ages where they're you know from
8 to 13 this is the opportunity of a
lifetime
to get good and bored and to figure out
what to do when you're bored and you
want to try to find something you're
interested in to explore I just want to
you know like the the big picture path
forward so here's here's what seems to
me to be very very evident we're going
to have this massive project in my mind
of trying to help our entire country
recover from this collective trauma that
we're experiencing right now that
certainly most devastating for people
who are more vulnerable in various ways
and so I would love your thoughts on
what national rebuilding of mental
health might look like well I mean
there's always the I mean the most
obvious which don't just never happens
is more resources for mental health
professionals because those offices are
overwhelmed even before this all
happened so we're gonna need that I want
to mention one other thing which I don't
know exactly how this would be regulated
or the policy solution but something I
think it's really important for parents
and policymakers to now is I think a
good amount of that increase in those ER
visits for self-harm and suicide
attempts happened because there are
websites that will tell people how to
harm themselves
there's also websites that will tell
kids how to starve themselves so they're
called pro-ana websites like
pro-anorexia and then there's all of
these that will actually tell kids how
to how to harm themselves and that you
know you talk about all of these other
influences that could be a good amount
of why we have such a huge increase in
self-harm and suicide attempts as well
is that that information is out there
and it used to be that a kid would have
to go to the computer in the family room
to look at it and the parent would be
like hey what is that
now with the smartphone they're looking
at it by themselves in their own room
starting sometimes at the age of 10 or a
younger we're all struggling and then
we're all struggling alone and you know
we need to come together and be like hey
if it's everyone's struggling and our
kids are struggling then maybe we should
do something about it like this is the
foundation of my campaign and why I'm so
like passionate and angry about this
where we're just maximizing capital
returns and saying well I guess that's
the purpose of our society while our
kids are getting sick and anxious and
depressed and like what's the point
like what like what's the point of high
GDP if you're all miserable and anxious
and even suicidal you know it's like
what kind what kind of society we
organize ourselves around so to me if
you're not getting it right for your
kids you're just getting it wrong
[Music]